what action is more heavy yeah your man
cheating or the fact that a woman
destroys her home for her children what
act is more heavy in a marriage respect
should still be there whether you like
your wife or not you should respect her
if you're going to step away can you
answer his questions
what what has more weight in it yeah a
man stepping out just busting a nut or
you breaking up a home where your kids
will suffer the results but you've just
you've what is more heavy what's more
heavy you as a man could have created
what is more heavy and the demand the
man so the man cheated yeah okay okay
okay this right there modern women
selfish I swear to God I swear to god
stop it stop it stop it stop it stop it
you're over talking me on my own show
that's rude uh like this is this is this
is the epitome modern women selfish
because you think because he did
something to you that is that is more
heavy than you doing something to your
children no I'm not saying that I didn't
say that I don't say that this is this
is
you've talked a lot today okay I've
given you a lot of mic time and I'm
saying like that like I actually forgot
what I was gonna say
what I'm saying is the man especially
when he has children he needs to
understand the repercussions is the
woman's going to be hurt she might not
get over it he's breaking up his family
home he's putting his selfish needs
ahead of his child no no no he's not
she's breaking like this is like like
women do something and we still put the
accountability on men you broke up the
home
you chose to leave okay I think we're
not understanding a man stepping up with
transparency is very different to a man
going behind her back and causing her if
he said to her let me finish sorry if he
said to her do you know what babe I need
to sexually [ __ ] this woman because that
is that is something of me I love you I
want to be in a marriage with you but I
just need to step out you're probably
still going to leave hold on hold on no
wait let me finish if she then decides
to leave that's on her if she decides to
say you know what he's told me and I
can't tolerate it I'm gonna break up my
child that's fine but if he's now gone
behind her back and she's found out and
she's reacting and said this
disrespectful very different this is a
nonsense this is just like a Fluff it's
like if you chose to leave then you're
responsible for leaving can I just like
with these two people here as she was
there at the beginning and she worked
just as hard as him I can understand the
wanting half but what I don't understand
is that if they've got children
and he cheated
and she's willing to screw up the family
because he's cheated everybody's gonna
say oh no she's right she's entitled to
because she cheated she's a woman but
look what she's putting that child
through if I get married again
so what's worse putting your child
through a second bad relationship or
sticking and working out with the
original father sorry I I'm struggling
yeah to understand how we're missing the
fact that he put the family in this
situation I don't think no look I'm not
saying that what he did in the room I'm
not saying what he did is wrong I'm just
saying that two Realms don't make her at
100 but him stepping out yeah and button
on us and we discussed how meaningless
sex can be to men we know how
meaningless it can be here so you're
gonna you're gonna break up a home over
something that was meaningless he's not
having he doesn't have another
relationship he's not providing
resources he doesn't love this woman
regardless of the situation as to why he
did it the reasons for him stepping out
do not equate to the reasons you're
breaking up a home
and men and women cheating is different
like how many women get attention from
other men all the time all the time look
at how half the girls on the show like
they'll be in a relationship I'll look
at their Instagram ass pic ass pick ass
pick that's cheating too but the thing
is is that everybody's saying that oh
then cheating's bad you're not supposed
to cheat but what's worse
forgiving your husband for cheating or
divorcing when you've got children and
putting your child through a second
marriage that you've left up I was going
to be more traumatic for the child at
the end of the day we've all been saying
that when you get married it's about the
child I'm not going to say that what he
done was right but what I'm saying that
what she done was worse hmm because she
didn't just leave and say I'm gonna
raise my child we're going to work out
and co-parent or I'm gonna forgive you
she went and married somebody else and
now she's getting divorced with that
person and that's what she's putting out
I think it's funny that we're saying
that the woman isn't taking
accountability this time the problem
starts with the man
no it does I just said that but you know
it's the way the way I think about
relationships and like marriage and
stuff yeah
I think it's it's a partnership
absolutely it is yeah I have to be right
to be able if I have children I have to
be right to be able to take care of my
children my partnership has to be strong
and solid for my children to be a good
result of this part this great
partnership right I understand that
that's cool I personally don't believe
in stay in in any situation because of
my children because I believe the way
I'm set up I might be more useful to my
children I might be a better mother to
my children if I'm not in a toxic
situation feminate
please let me finish I don't believe in
saying in a situation if someone cheats
for me to me I class that has toxic as
toxic because I know how it would affect
me this is personal to me so I don't
believe in me staying in a situation
because I don't want to break the fact
let me finish in my opinion
in a marriage you know you should know
your partner so you know what it is that
I want what I will tolerate and what I
won't tolerate you know the boundaries
I've said you know the vowels that I
that I shared with you if you cheat on
me
there's you you should have been you're
aware that there's a risk that I might
walk away
so if the family breaks up you are the
starting point of that you started that
basically use it as a risk it's not a
definite there's a risk
it was a definite
who said that he must know there's a
risk okay there's a risk this is a risk
infinite and he took the risk led us to
a broken family yeah
managing your emotions
managing my emotions does not mean me
tolerating [ __ ] does not mean
neglecting how I feel to be mature okay
okay okay okay as an adult it literally
does
literally it literally means managing
your emotions when things just don't go
your way
that you would do this and this and this
when you've got no children okay just
tell you what I would do but
I don't I don't need time
when they're pregnant you're going to
get the hormones you're going to get
feelings your feelings change then it
will change it but yeah
I'm gonna feel the same when I've had a
child when you've had a child talking to
you come back and tell me that when
you've had a child because as far as I'm
concerned it's totally different because
you're quite happy to say I've just
turned around and said I'm not excusing
his cheating he's married right to the
woman she's decided that she can't
accept his cheating so she's going to
divorce him fair enough what is worse
exception is cheating or putting the
child through a second of marriage
because surely it's got to be better to
forgive him move on get counseling for
her trauma and then get on with the
relationship and raise their child then
it is to put her child through a second
toxic relationship I hear you what I'm
trying to say and if we're gonna turn
around and say put your children first
all the women are going to say oh my
hormones I want to have my child I felt
like this that's what I'm trying to say
okay like a person that has no children
as many of you know you know is just
banned on Tick Tock and
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible